the state of nevada continues to pursue
the death penalty against a man who went
on a deadly shooting spree in las vegas
more than two decades ago
it's been court proceeding after court
proceeding leading up to his possible
execution
the i-team's vanessa murphy was in
federal court earlier today and is here
with more on what happened
denise prosecutors are seeking to
execute zane floyd the week of july
26th his defense team is asking for
clemency
the department of corrections still has
not publicly released
plans for the drugs to be used for
lethal injection and
other logistics floyd's lawyers have
been fighting for transparency
floyd is now 45 years old he shot and
killed four employees and injured
another at an
albertsons in 1999. he was sentenced to
death for murder and he was also
convicted of sexual assault
a federal judge has indicated he could
delay the execution
once floyd's defense attorneys are given
information about what drugs would be
used for lethal injection
he's pointed out they would need time to
respond and possibly file
additional motions in court so for now
there is no
definite execution date many moving
pieces here as the state tries to
execute the first
inmate in 15 years